it's great to welcome back to the
program attorney Mike Papantonio of
course co-hosts a ring of fire radio
hosts of america's lawyer quite a long
list of credentials including now being
author of the second book in the new
legal thriller series the second book is
called law and vengeance the first was
law and disorder PAP a lot of major
differences between the first and second
books first focused on work you've done
sort of in the pharmaceutical industry
pharmaceutical company wrongdoing
fictionalized into a legal thriller this
time you're sort of taking on is it fair
to say the military-industrial complex
weapons manufacturers yeah we're taking
on the weapons contractors and really in
effect taking on the Department of
Justice for their inability to get the
problems under control as you and I have
talked about I think you know I've done
stories on this independent of this book
in the past and it is that we we really
don't understand how many billions of
dollars is squandered away every year by
text but in tax money because weapons
manufacturers are scamming the US
government and the US government is
doing very little to get that money back
so this this book is actually based on a
case we've handled where we had a
weapons manufacturer that made a
defective sight they knew it was
defective kept it on the market anyway
ended up in deaths of people and so the
that's the underlying that's the
underlying theme of the case and the
protagonists a couple of them in this
case take that take that on after the
death of one of their partners so I it's
all it's all based on reality except for
the deaths that occur in both the law in
disorder and law and vengeance this is a
series as you pointed out the first one
is is law disorder the second one is lon
vengeance we're working right now I'm in
the process of trying to finish the
first round of of law and addiction and
then the third one about the opioid
crisis that exists the United States and
then the third the fourth one is a long
Terrorism about the US banks washing
money for terrorists all over the world
II know those are all cases that were
actually hand
in law and disorder you had a male
protagonist which i think is fair to say
was loosely based on on you this time
you've got I would call it the primary
protagonist is a female lawyer it what
what's different about writing for a
female protagonist having previously had
a male protagonist in your in your
stories well it's a different voice
obviously this particular this Geena
Romano is the is is that character and
she's really a composite of some of the
best female trial lawyers that I've
worked with over the years and it's it's
it's an important voice because right
now you would think that female trial
lawyers especially in the area of law
that there are no glass ceilings but
unfortunately there are and I'm
embarrassed by that for you know
fortunately there are people paying
attention to it right now but she she's
one of these characters that have worked
had to work her way through that
she's become one of the premier criminal
trial lawyers in America and she really
is a composite of several female trial
lawyers that I've worked with in the
past and a lot of the lot of the
backstory is actually of her backstory
is based on real events one of the sort
of underlying storylines of law
invention and vengeance also is the
issue of whistleblowers in the United
States and the sort of legal context
around whistleblowers why did you decide
to him decide to include that as an
element in the story was it anything you
saw under the Obama administration it's
everything about the Obama
administration we had Obama coming out
and saying that gee whiz this is going
to be the era of whistleblowers we're
going to protect them we're going to
make sure when they do come out and they
they get money back for taxpayers that
we're going to make sure that they're
protected and unfortunately under Obama
we saw the worst record for
whistleblowers that even worse than
George Bush it was it was a war with
whistleblowers and what would end up
happening is a whistleblower would come
forward with a case that whistleblower
would often end up in prison not
not the corporation he's blowing the
whistle on the blue so blower would end
up in prison
the government would then settle the
case against the corporation that the
whistle blower was trying to uncover and
they would make millions and tens of
millions of dollars and the
whistleblower ends up sitting in prison
as these as these cases unfold it was
just it was the biggest scam it was the
biggest scam Department of Justice era
that I can ever remember even word and I
hate to say it it was actually worse
than the Bush era which was awful but
you had a you had a Department of
Justice under you know Loretta Lynch
even with Loretta Lynch you'd have
thought that she was going to turn
things around but she was no different
than holder holder was awful holder
would find these companies that had
committed murder there's no other way to
put it pharmaceutical companies that
actually killed people with dangerous
drugs whistleblower would come forward
tell that story whistleblower would be
minimized
maybe not thrown in prison but minimized
the Department of Justice would then
proceed against the pharmaceutical
industry or that particular drug maker
find that find the drug maker a couple
hundred million dollars maybe a billion
dollars and and nobody goes to prison
from that Corporation and understand it
was conduct that it absolutely would
would rise to manslaughter in any other
world had the CEOs of that corporation
worn hoodies and men straight sitting on
the standing on the street corner in New
York they'd gone to prison but here you
know the guy with a briefcase he can
steal a lot more than a man with a gun
and never end up going to prison and
that was really a reflection of what I
remember about this Department of
Justice I don't think it's gonna get
much better to tell you the truth but I
think I was I was really angered by this
this notion that Obama was putting out
there that he's doing so much for the
whistleblower and he really wants
disclosure of bad conduct in this
company and he's really on the side of
the consumer rather than the corporation
and every single thing he did or that
his Department of Justice did was
contrary to that understand Holder Eric
Holder who was the first man in charge
of the DOJ he was actually he came up
through
ranks of covington burling one of the
biggest white-collar silk stockings
defense firms in america and all they
did was represented big corporations for
criminal conduct
so then Eric Holder steps into the shoes
of the top the number one policeman in
the country and he puts none of them
jailed they stole a trillion dollars in
the Wall Street burned down and nobody
went to jail so this book exposes kind
of the underpinnings of the Department
of Justice and all the problems that
need to be corrected and unfortunately
we can't expect those to be corrected
under a trump administration it's
incredible that we're talking about your
legal thriller write a fiction book but
we're also talking about the reality of
whistleblowers under the Obama
administration and a case that you
actually handled and as part of the
reason why we maybe aren't hearing about
this through a nonfiction book that we
often see cases settled out of court
with non-disclosure agreements
confidentiality agreements gag orders
throughout the process etc is it a sort
of way to liberate yourself and be able
to tell these stories under the umbrella
of fiction by writing these books that's
exactly it
these stories will you understand these
stories will never be told this story
I'm working on right now in the opioid
crisis that's the case we're actually
working on right now that story will
never be told the back story will never
be told because here again the
Department of Justice let these drug
dealers who are wearing Armani suits
they let these drug dealers get away
with a slap on the hand with a you know
a a couple of a hundred million dollar
fine for killing hundreds of thousands
of people indirectly all over this
country all over the world with with
drugs that they understood we're going
to do exactly that they made it into a
business enterprise they took all of the
bad things that surrounded the the use
of opioids in this country the pill
mills the diversion all of the things
that were taking place they knew where
they were taking place they knew exactly
what was happening and they actually
built all those bad things into their
business plan but in the end what did
the Department of Justice do these are
companies
pled guilty they absolutely pled guilty
that is wrong conduct and nobody went to
prison so the cases that we're handling
right now we're going to continue
telling the story and our the next book
will tell the stories but law and
vengeance law and vengeance tells
stories they tell the back stories on
things that people don't hear about them
in corporate media house corporate media
going to talk about the defense how are
they going to talk about McDonnell
Douglas or Boeing or any of the defense
industry when big when so much of their
budget their advertising money comes
from there so they don't tell the story
government doesn't tell the story
because these are done insight and it's
secret they're done behind closed doors
they're done where there's gag orders
and nobody can talk about it but but I
don't settle the case where I can't talk
about it that's not something I do we've
been talking about the book law and
vengeance which comes out September 26th
by attorney Mike Papantonio available
now for pre-order on Amazon link is in
the youtube description for our segment
PAP pleasure is always talking to you
and good luck with the book I'm 5 or 10
pages from finishing it and it's been a
great read
thank you David I appreciate that